you
hello everybody welcome
uh it is may 25th
this is off the rails
you know
today's obviously not going to be a
normal episode because we're going to
talk about
what happened in texas yesterday
and
um
it's it's
you know
i was i was so disturbed
when i learned about it i mean
i think the fact that i have two young
children now it hits me harder than it
ever did before
this kind of stuff happens all the time
right i mean it happened
how long ago was sandy hook now for like
10 years decade
happened 10 years ago
about the same amount of kids who were
slaughtered by a psycho
in an elementary school
uh was it 20 19 then
19 yes and so this time it's 19 as well
oh oh then sorry yeah uh
i don't remember how many it was in san
diego
it's a similar number actually 26 people
were killed 20 of the victims were
children
and you know there's like there was a
shooting just recently
that was like racially motivated that
was so depressing
but to go and and to specifically go to
hurt children i mean is there anything
more evil
it's just so disturbing you know
children are so innocent and pure and
just undeserving of of
it really is like i think the only pure
evil thing that happens in the world
and a vacuum is just harming children in
any way it you know
yeah so 19 kids were and two
i guess it was how many teachers died
two teachers and then two officers or
because i know there was like 19
uh
19 children
or killed
and two adults
um
and when you see the pictures of these
kids man it's like
dude
you know
barely older than my than my oldest son
who's three years old
and they're just so sweet and innocent
at that age i mean
yeah so
it's it was just so disturbing man and
you're desensitized to it because in
america that happens all the time you
know there's like a chart
what's happening amy
okay
it's hard to talk
everything okay back there
okay
we're good now sorry
um
you know this stuff happens all the time
and we do get desensitized but man
there's no shock to the system like 19
children
being slaughtered
[Music]
it's crazy too how like
it's so obvious that something needs to
be done right i mean like
it's so painfully obvious that we as a
country have
pitifully
uh
failed to protect our children i mean
school shootings at this point is like a
national past time
it's basically baseball at this point
you know baseball apple pie and school
shootings that's what america is all
about
i mean love you're you're you live in
europe i mean what does it what's what's
your reaction when it's like oh yeah
this [ __ ] happens like every [ __ ]
just basically
like hunt literally hundreds of times a
year
school shootings
yeah i mean there there's no other
country in the world where or not
literally but most countries near me
this doesn't happen once like in a
lifetime
and it's so weird how america the
greatest country in the world
has
these major issues it's like
mind-blowing how
how it's like a part of daily life there
well when i was a kid
when i was a kid we didn't worry about
security guards and having guns on
school and stuff you know these days if
you go to a if you go to a public school
or private school i mean theodore's
private school there's like a shitload
of armed guards
look at this
isn't this great um school shootings by
country this is just this year
no no no it says 2022. i think it just
means it's up to date
so check this out 288 in the united
states
uh the second one is eight in mexico
most european countries are
you know one
we're sweden on here any there just
because love's here i don't see sweden
on the board at all
yeah i don't recall having a shooting
we've had attacks i guess where things
have happened but never shooting
from my experience
there you go
it's as american as apple pie folks
it's so painfully obvious to everyone
that something needs to be done
you know
and yet nothing does right
there's already like spin
on on like you know fox news on twitter
all the usual suspects my favorite is
that the the shooter had like a hispanic
last name so of course all the uh or
people start speculating oh he's an
illegal alien this is an immigration
issue can you [ __ ] believe that [ __ ]
evil
it's actually evil
to spin it like that i mean i think
they're going to hell
i actually do
um
yeah
and everyone's saying that i was wrong
that is just 20 22.
yo
no way
that's what i thought because i remember
hearing there's been pull that up again
that's i remember seeing something like
there's been hundreds that's just you
that get is that really the world we're
living in
pull that up
a school shooting used to make the news
that used to be big news now
that's like every day this year or more
than every day that's like two a day
two a day
can you pull that back up please
how far into the year are we it's may 25
not that far
are you [ __ ] kidding me 288
just this year
that that can't be right i think chat's
just wrong
i saw that stat man it might be right
dude they're all spamming that that's
from 2022 but that's not that can't be
true i'm seeing a report from npr
um
that back
a few days ago 213 mass shootings
in america this year that's mass
shootings not in school specifically
though right right okay mass shootings
fine
yeah npr a few years ago it's 27 school
shootings so far in 2022 27 yeah
so that's yeah
so
so let's just go with 27 then
it's may okay
27 divided by five
that's five and a half school shootings
a month
and you don't hear about them that's
what's crazy dude i mean you hear about
them when they're really horrific like
this
five
and a half school shootings per month
bro
and so you go to public schools
and they have like armed guards
metal detectors our [ __ ] schools are
turning into a refuge or turning into
like
demilitarized zones
and so
of course on the right the solution is
we need more guns
teachers who teachers need more guns
which of course
again you're you're just going to hell
if you think that i'm sorry if you think
the answer is arming teachers you're
just gonna you're going to hell when you
die
i don't care how much you love jesus
he's going to [ __ ] send your ass to
hell
you really think that huh
the answer is more guns
well nothing's working right
because we keep putting more guns in
schools we're trying to whatever we're
doing now
is clearly not working right
okay it's been 10 years
since someone massacred children
in a place where they should feel safe
nothing's actually it's gotten worse i
think probably school i think shootings
has gone up like 100 since then so not
so what we're doing isn't working right
which i think what we're doing currently
is nothing to
making it worse adding more guns to the
school
i just love the idea of a teacher
who's already like underappreciated
has to get a degree in education and
take care of a bunch of kids now has to
[ __ ] get trained now they gotta go do
boot camp
and get they they need to become
warriors
to ready to to uh
to uh draw their pistols
um
and you know these kids are always
armored to their teeth right again ar
ar-15 body armor this kid who did it has
so
maybe we should just give teachers like
bazookas bro
i mean we need we need they need
adequate weaponry right
like what's the best defense against
ar-15 and body armor maybe they need
like uh
tactical head vision uh night vision
you know
maybe some kind of like uh
definitely some kind of rocket launcher
would be good for the teachers to have i
think
flamethrower perhaps that'd be that's a
good way to stand your ground i think we
should arm teachers with flame throwers
that sounds like a that sounds like the
answer to this right
does anyone um
maybe you know what could work um
tactical nuke actually
take them all out
blow up the whole school let god sort
them out right that's what the nra says
the nras put out a statement teachers
must have tactical nukes to deal with
this
and so that's that's actually a really
good idea from them
maybe you know we should give teachers
maybe just some like uh
uh not what do you call those knuckle
weapons
uh brass knuckles they need brass
knuckles just in case it goes day hand
to hand or perhaps a bayonet
for if it goes to hand to hand combat
they should definitely have a knife on
their on their
on their belt at all times for for armed
combat right
maybe land mines
in the hallway they can trip them
proximity bombs do you guys what do you
guys think land mines could work
yeah i think um
i think those are all really good ideas
that nra's put putting forward there
yeah but nothing's working right
um
didn't schumer put out a statement
saying no gun laws coming what was that
i saw aoc tweet about that
schumer and you know
my thing now after this is
um
i think i gotta go single issue i think
gun
gun reform is going to be a single issue
for me
it's the only thing that matters
i'm solely voting based on
gun reform
because that's really the only way like
we will never move conservatives on this
issue
like it happened where 26 children got
slaughtered sandy hook 10 years ago
it happened now they're already spinning
it
we will never move conservatives right
it's it's sad but true
the only way to do it is to vote
and you know
the democrats are no better they just
[ __ ] in uh in texas right was it were
the democrats backed was it in texas
that [ __ ] democrat who's
anti-abortion pro-gun
yes uh henry
cuellar i believe yeah the democratic
party
campaigned
for a
pro-life i shouldn't say pro-life i
should call them like [ __ ]
forced birth i should call him like a
forced birth candidate you know what i
mean
he's forced birth
and pro-gun and the democrats just
pushed him through
heavily supported him to be a
progressive and he lost he won by like a
hundred votes too it was [ __ ]
disgusting vile
[Music]
yeah
um
you guys should see how much money these
republicans take from the nra man
people like ted cruz have taken like
literally like three over three million
dollars from the nra you basically just
work for them at that point
someone gives you three million bucks
you work for them
so nothing's changing
nothing's gonna change
so
we just gotta vote man
people need to care about elections
i know a lot of stuff is [ __ ] right
in elections but a lot of stuff isn't
[ __ ]
this one's not [ __ ]
because
we have
five and a half shootings per month
school shootings per month
five and a half school shootings
per month in america
there's never been one in sweden
that's crazy right and it's always the
ar-15 pretty much this dude was using
one
i don't know what's with the gun people
man they're like cultists you know i was
talking about it on twitter
and a lot of the stuff i'm seeing in
response is people like um
who's going he wants to ban all guns
dude it's never going to happen we have
a constitution
gun reform doesn't mean banning all guns
dude
just shut the [ __ ] up you know that just
you're in a cult man snap the [ __ ] out
of it
there's a cult there's a cult of guns in
this country
you know
straight up
they'll love jesus too somehow we love
jesus and guns oh
and you know all the usual talking
points are proven [ __ ] in this fight
or in the shooting because they go all
you need is a guy
with a gun a good guy with a gun stops a
bad guy with a gun
so
the gunman crashed into the school
the police were called and showed up
he took he shot two of them
okay
so the good guys with guns showed up
right two of them he shot him both
more police arrived guess what the
police did
guess what the good guys with guns did
go ahead play the jeopardy music guess
what the good guys with guns did guys
yep
they just sat outside
they retreated
and let him
have free reign
over the elementary school
and they sat outside and listened as
gunshots went off
for 30 to 40 minutes
as he slaughtered 19 children and all
the good guys with guns outside who
complain about how dangerous their job
is the cops
the support police
they just sat and listened to the
gunshots ring out for 30 to 40 minutes
as a
absolute [ __ ] hell on earth
um
happened right before their eyes
you know
am i not justified in thinking how
pathetic the police are
for that
i mean i'm serious
they want to be heroes they want to talk
about how dangerous their job is
they had the opportunity to save
children
and they sat outside and listened
as [ __ ] shots rang out shot after
shot after shot
in a [ __ ] elementary school
and they waited for backup for 30 to 40
minutes
how [ __ ] sick is that
and it's scary man
it's scary you know
i i'm not a brave person but i'm not a
cop either right
so
i'm just saying
they want to be treated
as heroes and with reverence and [ __ ]
respect and ah they put their they're
just they're so they put their lives on
the line
where were they
uh
where were they
you know
but that that there goes your good guy
with the gun theory
there was there was there was a shitload
of good guys with guns there and how and
how able were they to stop this
um
how did they do
how'd the good guys with the guns do
i'll tell you how they did 19 kids died
two adults
so so much for that huh
now if only they had you know
more armory they could they could have
stopped them i'm sure
i'm sure they could have done something
if they just had
more more a higher budget for sure would
have would have saved those kids for the
police of course
robocop perhaps
could have saved those kids maybe
now we're talking and uh
privatized robotic cyborgs yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's what elon can help out
with that because obviously the the
obviously
the the solution isn't to restrict uh
gun a gun reform right that's not an
option so
maybe some kind of lasers in schools
positioned throughout the hallways that
can just evaporate some uh evaporate
people lasers would be a good idea
we're investing in that what's the nra
stance on lasers in poli you know
schools interesting
so there you guys have it
good guys with guns
and by the way this is a
the shooter was an 18 year old kid
versus a trained military force okay
he took out two cops an 18 year old kid
he bought his weapon or he was he was
yeah he was 18 he bought his weapons
when he was 18. okay
he hasn't even had the weapons that long
you know thwarted an entire police force
that's incredible
that's incredible my guys
isn't that nuts
is that absolutely unbelievable
he thwarted a whole police force for 30
to 40 minutes
damn
good guys with guns man where were they
yeah so this kid who's responsible
obviously extremely unwell and you know
dealing with this issue it's it's not
one thing right like
something this terrible doesn't happen
regularly
unless there's a multitude of [ __ ]
problems of which there are
the two main ones of course is
healthcare
this this dude was very [ __ ] sick in
the head
and if we had it more
you know it's impossible to say you know
but
if we had a more comprehensive free
caring
if we had an empathetic
health care system where there was an
easy way for people like this to get
treated
i think that would cut down on these
things happening probably even more than
gun reform i'll be honest and
conservatives say that too right they
say that and then nothing happens they
go this is a mental health issue not a
gun issue we say okay let's [ __ ] do
something about that then nothing
happens
there's people on twitter conservatives
just being like that's just the way it
is dude
it's our constitutional right man that's
just the way it is brother
some kids got to die for my right to
bear arms brother
that's just the cost of doing business
did you see the uh go ahead the onion
today
no show me so they regularly post
the same article anytime there's a mass
shooting
no way to prevent this
says only nation where this regularly
happens and if you haven't noticed it's
literally every article
good for them
that's [ __ ] great
yeah it's so true actually
you're gonna see people saying that too
it's it's it's i mean it's actually just
[ __ ]
incredible yeah they're out there saying
that there's no way to prevent this man
i'm sure there's some good conservative
takes you can probably pull
i have a lot for uh tomorrow on
leftovers because i'm assuming throw up
some choice ones from discussion will
spill over into tomorrow definitely
definitely definitely um let me open the
leftover stock real quick by the way
here's aoc
ted cruz who's [ __ ] going to hell for
sure
um heidi and i are fervently lifting up
impaired they're praying extra hard
today guys
other days we don't praise hard
today's a big prayer day
hold on to that for a sec but yeah
today's a big big prayer day in the
cruise family
they are praying fervently
for the children and families
thank you to heroic law enforcement are
you sure
heroic law enforcement
are you talking about the guys that sat
outside for 34 minutes listening to
shots ring out in elementary school as
19 children were
methodically executed
are you thinking that heroic law
enforcement okay
got it
uh aoc says aren't you slated to
headline a speaking gig for the nra in
three days in houston no less
yeah you can do more than pray
[ __ ] oh man
um this is just i wanted to show you
guys kind of
the conservative takes going out in the
world right now
we'll talk more about this tomorrow but
here's charlie kirk
pay close attention to how quickly the
media shifts their message from
potential white supremacy
to gun control
after learning
when did anybody that literally didn't
even happen well and this this really
should be taken as a twofer and i
apologize because it's twitter it's
reverse chronological orders okay let me
read the first tweet
if you are attempting to politicize the
senseless murder of 14 innocent children
right now you should probably stop pray
for the families
pay close yeah so i mean how about you
just shut the [ __ ] up and go to hell how
about that
it's incredible
this nobody buys that [ __ ] anymore
don't please don't don't politicize this
how about you [ __ ] go to hell bro
that's such that's like the most
laughable [ __ ]
take ever
how dare you want to do something to fix
the situation that just happened
we need to you know we need to pray
super hard man
so if they're clearly not praying hard
enough because this [ __ ] keeps happening
in fact five and a half times a month
why is the prayer not working you guys
they're praying i mean ted cruz is
praying super [ __ ] hard right now
fervently
you know what i'm saying usually ted
cruz is like this
but that day he was like this
bro you're in the [ __ ] congress dude
you don't have to pray super hard you
can actually do [ __ ] isn't that crazy
praying is for people who are powerless
you're actually in congress dude
isn't that nuts how that works so you
can actually do something about it you
[ __ ] spineless creep you're going to
l2
ted cruz is going to hell
charlie
kirk is going to help
actually
um straight up
incredible huh
i mean it's possible i mean listen i'm
gonna be open-minded about this but is
it possible that enough people didn't
pray hard enough and that's why this
happened
is it possible that not enough prayer
from the last one
you tell me you're godless heathen
i don't know it's possible maybe people
just didn't pray hard enough
how hard have you prayed
ethan
dude i haven't prayed at all actually
and that's what i'm saying maybe this is
part my fault
maybe this is the big of you to admit
that maybe this is partially my fault
for not praying bigger you to admit that
you know
yeah shout out to the heroes i love that
why are police always heroes why are the
police always [ __ ] heroes you don't
even know bro
they're cut in this case they're
absolute cowards that enabled they could
have stopped this isn't that crazy
they could have stopped this
they met him before he even went into
into school
those men are not heroes
um
they're actually
[ __ ]
disgusting cowards
jesus you see what zach just sent
the trump post yeah
america needs real solutions and real
leadership in this moment not
politicians and partisanship
that's why i will keep my long-time
commitment to speak in texas at the nra
convention and deliver an important
address to america
in the meantime we all continue to pray
pray hard baby
so
okay great that makes sense
that's a perfect plan of action yeah
absolutely jesus christ
oh god
uh
um
let's continue so
oh you know what's the best part about
this guys is that the parents right of
the 19 slain children
are now going to be harassed by people
uh the ilk of alex jones who are going
to say that this is a false flag
operation you can bet on it the parents
who just lost their children
were just torn from them violently
horrifically
the most painful way you can imagine
losing a child my god they died in
horror
okay
are now going to be [ __ ] harassed by
the ilk of alex jones
guaranteed it they're going to be called
crisis actors
and they're going to be called
fakes
and that's a special nod to joe rogan
who by the way
is not only constantly promoting alex
jones but when recently someone called
him out for his affiliation with alex
jones
dan
doug stanhope maybe you could pull that
clip up he called him out like why are
you like are you really hanging out with
alex jones and he goes dude alex is
legit he's right about a lot of stuff
as he's being sued by the families of
sandy hook for [ __ ] saying they're
lying about their kids dying guys this
is not a joke
how can you casually just partake in
that
yeah well you can bet these parents are
going to be harassed
it's going to [ __ ] happen it might
already be happening isn't that awesome
oh yeah good fine dan here it is check
this out
stanhope questions joe on his uh
relationship with alex jones here
do you know the fastest growing cable
news no i don't tell me what is it i'll
give you a hint block doesn't work on
this website news nation no way
we are telling stories that matter
watch our episode get taken down for
having a baked in ad now
maybe mute the audio yeah thank you yeah
yo
no way news nation
[ __ ] yeah dude
i've literally never heard of that in my
life me neither
news nation
the last thing we need now is more news
i just you know what i mean the
landscape is a little bear i i don't
agree
there's not nearly enough news i think
we have a [ __ ] enough news outlets
okay here's doug stanhope questioning uh
joe rogan on his relationship with alex
jones john started in austin we were
more popular than him and he did this
cable access thing yeah and then that
guy charlie he's like yeah he's just
being a cartoon
he's trying to sell tickets and then he
bought his own [ __ ] well he's right
about enough things that it's very
confusing you know alex jones was right
about spaghetti against the wall no no
no no one of those strips is he's
absolutely right
he didn't invent any of these these are
all conspiracies that are floating
around in the ether before he ever
uttered them mm-hmm so
no he's right about more than spaghetti
and so that's why we know about
operation northwoods no no no no anyway
that's about it but
you know what's crazy is that joe rogan
i would say is definitely partially
responsible for the parents who are now
going to be harassed by uh the ilk of
alex jones
uh
you think alex will be dumb enough to no
no not he won't now no but but many
people will
many people will alex is he's about to
lose literally everything in these sandy
hook lawsuits which god bless you know
god bless
but i don't think alex jones is even
going to open his [ __ ] mouth about
this he hasn't talked about sandy hook
in years because since the lawsuits
i'd be shocked if he does
maybe he doesn't give a [ __ ] maybe he
has nothing left to lose but yeah [ __ ]
you joe rogan you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you know it's nice having alex jones on
because you get lots of views
he's a lightning rod how i mean his
views with alex have tens millions of
views
but weigh that
against children [ __ ] dying and their
parents being harassed
dude
actually
an update on all of that i'm seeing from
just yesterday
um
sandy hook families uh defamation uh
damages trial against auctions to move
forward a federal judge cleared the way
for sandy hook families to have the
defamation lawsuit they won against alex
jones released from bankruptcy
protection right because he declared
bankruptcy to
essentially
you know try and get out of owing them
anything and apparently they are saying
nope
dude it's going to be so good to watch
him lose everything to these families
i'm so
so happy to see it they're good it's
going to go to a jury trial and they're
going to decide how much
he owes
even keemstar's got the right take isn't
that amazing
something has to be done keemstar says
ban all guns
or put armed guards in every school okay
well we're halfway there every time
every time
you gotta kind of you gotta kind of pick
a lane dude
you gotta pick a lane
the solution is either less guns or more
guns well let's do the same guys but
right now we're at a really just bad
level of guns we need to either pump
those gun numbers way up or down you
know what we need is a federal army
of troops that are going to be stationed
in every school
that's basically what we need
we need like a school army
the child protection army
that sounds nice that's a nice ring to
it
are we [ __ ] over is america over
might be
once you're talking about the national
children's defense against shooter funds
i think the country's over
well if we can't fix this i think the
country's over just straight up like if
we can't address this now
i think it's over guys i think it's time
to wrap up the american experiment
the chat's suggesting just why not arm
the kids
right well that the tudor was 18 and he
was a good shot clearly with the police
he encountered the police so the kit i
mean well here let me show you something
that's kind of relevant
uh so
the shooter bought his weapons online
from a web from a a gun manufacturer
called daniel's defense
allegedly we should say
this is still kind of being oh no but it
seems they removed the picture do you
guys have a screenshot i did i backed it
up because i had a feeling they were
going to delete that one second
no dan oh they deleted their whole
twitter page
yeah what a surprise or did they just
block me because i retweeted it oh well
that's possible too wait they this is
the podcast
then yeah they probably just got off of
twitter so
no this i think it okay so this is the
allegedly now
the shooter's instagram post it's been
confirmed by a bunch of his classmates
that it is his account
so it's been corroborated so
he bought an ar-15 online god bless the
internet right only in america
can you buy a ar-15 online and that's
got to be true
that's got to be true
yeah so daniel defense made it and they
just posted this may um gosh may 16th
gosh that was just [ __ ] a couple weeks
ago yeah
love says only in america and you buy a
ar period dude ars are just rifles
they're just normal rifles you you
literally don't know anything about guns
that's what i mean that's what the
that's what they say
like why is it the ar-15s are used in
every mass shooting dude it's just a
rifle bro you don't unders you clearly
don't know anything about guns do you
even know the ar doesn't stem for
assault rifle i was about to
i was just about to cut in and say do
you even know what ar stands for yeah
because if you don't you don't get to
have an opinion on this you don't get to
have an opinion on children i know that
they keep using the same gun to kill
[ __ ] kids
you know
scroll up a little bit dan yeah so this
is the manufacturer daniel defense okay
nine days ago train up a child in the
way he should go
and when he is old
he will not depart from it my favorite
is the
so the kid's holding i think that's an
ar-15 right
ar-15 type rifle yes
and he's got a clip with bullets in it
next to him
the kid is that's called a magazine not
a clip right you're showing your you
clearly have you have no right there you
have no right to have an opinion on
children being murdered until you learn
all of the nomenclature for rifles okay
right
apologies i need to go do some homework
but
this kid doesn't seem interested in
playing with this gun with a loaded
magazine on on the floor but the dad you
know being a good christian dad he's
saying no you have to [ __ ] learn you
have to shoot this thing
so um
this is a dope post
for a gun manufacturer who posted this
nine days before mass shooting that
killed 19 children
and they use their weapon
dope and so that's why i say these gun
people it's literally a cult it's
[ __ ] a cult
it really is you know this post is just
mind bending i mean it's so [ __ ]
gross
besides the fact that somebody used
their gun to slaughter 19 children nine
days or like almost eight days later
even you know
besides that little fact
it's disgusting
i just love that even in their pulse the
dad's like you have to play with this
thing even though you don't want to
you're just a child
look at the angry finger right
you you will
all right get it off my screen [ __ ]
hate it
incredible stuff right guys
daniel's uh daniel's defense
they gotta do my name like that sorry
daniel come on
bought it online ladies and gentlemen
um yeah he bought this thing online
for 1800 bucks
2000 after a tax
apparently he worked part-time at
wendy's
to save up
and buy that on his 18th birthday
um
i'm not going to say his name by the way
this guy can go to [ __ ] hell and be
forgotten anyone that says shooter's
name what is wrong with you
what's wrong with you are people really
saying that on the news and [ __ ] like
have we not learned like every
psycho at like every uh you know
professional
psychiatrist who
studies this the one thing they always
say is don't say the [ __ ] name
because they crave that attention and it
just inspires more people to do the same
don't say their [ __ ] name don't deify
these people um and they still do it
stop
how people still say the [ __ ] name
what is wrong with you
this guy this guy's [ __ ] you know
he's dust bro he's done he's meaningless
his life is meaningless his existence is
his existence is [ __ ] gone dude
there'll be no legacy for him you
understand
don't say his [ __ ] name man
jesus christ how many times do people
have to tell you this it's mind-blowing
[ __ ] dude
[ __ ]
just say the gunman 18 year old who will
not be named was killed who [ __ ]
needs to know his name
it's crazy man it's [ __ ] nuts dude
he started by shooting his grandmother
and then he went to the school
uh nate oh so this is what happened the
neighbors called 9-1-1 after he shot his
grandma and reported that he was going
to the school
they couldn't have had a better
opportunity to stop him i'll be honest
there's a whole [ __ ] gang of good
guys with guns
he shot his grandma
the neighbors call 911 said he's going
to the school
where's the good guys with guns man
it's almost like
they could have not even come and the
result would have been the same isn't
that nuts man
so
of course the good guys with the guns
did
i mean they did stop him eventually yeah
40 minutes later
and ironically a border patrol agent not
a police officer was the one who took
him down which is
that is interesting this guy had time to
come from the border i don't know closer
to the border fairly close i mean close
enough that there's a border patrol
agent
can you imagine
i have a hard time with this
you're a police officer
waiting outside of school elementary
school listening
to shots ring out inside people
screaming right
and you wait outside
for 30 to 40 minutes shots ring out
inside of elementary school
must have been i mean to kill 19 people
must have been hundreds of rounds
30 to 40 minutes
the [ __ ]
what cowards
what [ __ ]
cowards
oh my god it's so upsetting
heroes though
um
more officers arrived
including a border patrol officer
and then they went in
oof
this thing
maybe just sent is a
i don't even know i don't even know what
word i have for it
the school district
rob elementary has its own police
department with five cops and one
security guard
the city of uvalde's police department
received just under 40
of the entire city's budget for the year
and got a 500 000 grant from the state
wow
how dude that's like 40
of the entire city budget you guys got
the call
you got the call
you intercepted him at the school
and you waited outside
well he killed 19
children
slaughtered them
you know is it really that crazy to ask
for uh police reform do you know how
much money we spend on that [ __ ]
a social worker going in there trying to
talk him down would have probably a
higher chance of disarming darn of
disarming him
than the [ __ ] police were working
with him
years in advance so that he never got to
such a dark place that he decided that
this was something worth doing right
that's the healthcare angle yeah
yo that's staggering man the school
district ha so it sounds like there
already is a um
we already have a kids uh uh military
force five cops and one security card
just for the school district
40
of the entire city's budget
and this should still happen man how
[ __ ] crazy that's
mind-blowing
uh hassan since everyone loves talking
[ __ ] about how dangerous a cops have it
here are some numbers in 2022 19
students died in school shootings
20 cops died in the gunfire so it you
know it's a cop being a kid at school is
just only a close second in terms of
being dangerous
yeah
it's wild
being a student is as dangerous as being
a cop in america
there's no problem though
there's no problem right
there's no problem
there's nothing we can do about it
there's nothing
you know
wish there was something we could do
about it
but unfortunately it's just you know
second amendment
um
this was a good thing that the the head
coach steve kerr
of the golden state warriors
came out
to talk about a
basketball game
and uh this was his
reaction
what happened with our not going to talk
about basketball nothing's
happened with our team in the last six
hours
we're going to start the same way
tonight
any basketball questions don't matter
um
since we left shoot around 14 children
were killed 400 miles from here
and a teacher
and in the last 10 days we've had
elderly black people killed in a
supermarket
in buffalo we've had asian church-goers
killed
in southern california and now we have
children murdered at school
when are we gonna do something
i'm tired i'm i'm so tired of getting up
here and
offering condolences to
to the
devastated families that are out there
i'm so tired of the excuse i'm sorry i'm
tired of the moments of silence
enough
there's 50 senators
right now who refused to vote on hr8
which is a background check rule that
the house passed a couple years ago it's
been sitting there for two years
and there's a reason they won't vote on
it to hold on to power
so i ask you mitch mcconnell i ask all
of you senators who refuse to do
anything about the violence and school
shootings and supermarket shootings i
ask you
are you going to put your own
desire for power ahead of the lives
of our children and our elderly and our
church-goers
because that's what it looks like
it's what we do every week
so
i'm fed up i've had enough
we're going to play the game tonight
but i want every person here every
person listening to this to think about
your own child or grandchild or mother
or father or sister brother how would
you feel if this happened to you today
we can't get numb to this we can't sit
here and just read about it and go well
let's have a moment of silence yeah go
dubs you know
come on mavs let's go
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
go play a basketball game and 50
senators in washington are going to hold
us hostage
do you realize that 90 percent of
americans
regardless of political party want
background check universal background
check 90 of us we are being held hostage
by 50 senators
in washington who refuse to even put it
to a vote despite
what we the american people want
they won't vote on it because they want
to hold on to their own power it's
pathetic i've had enough
and just to know another reason why he
takes it so personally is because steve
kerr's father when he was 19 was
murdered he was an educator he was
working overseas and he was killed by a
gunman
overseas yeah where uh in beirut lebanon
yeah
that's horrible yeah
uh so obviously i actually i found his
speech not only moving but interesting
in that he mentioned the bill uh
h
it's called the bipartisan background
checks act
and it's so funny you know to me because
it's called the by patterson
backgrounds check
the legislation would require background
checks for gun transfer between private
parties
the bill would require people selling
guns to one another to use a third-party
licensed arm dealer to facilitate the
sale so they can process background
checks for buyers this would close a
long-standing gun show loophole
to purchase guns without a check yet if
you go to a gun show right now there's
no background check you can [ __ ] buy
anything
and so this is what people are up in
arms about
we can't even pass common sense
gun laws
right
they go you're trying to take away all
guns it's like actually what we're
trying to do is the least [ __ ]
possible thing
do background checks on people
gun people need to [ __ ] wake up and
get real we need gun people to come to
the table and [ __ ] make some
concessions or this will never
ever
change
i've seen quite a few in our chat people
that say that they're gun owners and
they're generally programmed but the you
know
that they agree that we're at a
point of no return here
i own a gun i'm a gun owner i'm how do i
you know what i mean it doesn't i'm not
against gun ownership why why can't
people understand that
it's [ __ ] insane that like it's all
or nothing
this is the most basic common sense law
it passed through the house in 2019
but
uh sat they but the republicans refused
to bring it uh to a house vote to a
senate vote
i don't know how that's possible it just
went to a committee and died i mean
that's [ __ ] insane it happens all the
time it's just like a it's just one of
the many ways they use procedural [ __ ]
to uh to hold things up both sides do it
you know
to their advantage in one way or another
but let you get rid of that
yeah if you guys want an idea
if you say voting doesn't matter and
don't get me wrong democrats are [ __ ]
coward pieces of [ __ ] what they did in
texas to that
that one representative who's
pro-forced birth and pro-guns
[Music]
let's see
219 democrats voted yes
one democrat voted no
eight republicans voted yes
202 republicans
voted no
to the most basic common sense
gun law
so i mean i don't think it's a
stretch to say that republicans are the
pro-dead children party
republicans are the pro-slaughtering
kids at school party because they're
basically
the ones stopping any progress here in
terms of gun reform in the most basic
it's [ __ ] pathetic but i guess in the
wake of this happening it just got
through they said okay so we'll put it
through the senate now
right
just yesterday
so i guess that's a little encouraging
is that for sure i just i don't see any
i don't see any literature about this
bill going through to the senate there
there's been some more talk about it
today i mean it again all that means is
that it's been advanced in the committee
it'll need to go through committees and
then you know
the senate submits their version of it
and then there's reconciliation where
they have to make the
the house version of the bill and the
senate version of the bill
match or
coincide with each other and then it
gets a vote and yada yada
it's a whole process but yeah the point
is that the process is now seemingly
happening at all whereas it's literally
just been stalled out for a long time i
mean the funny thing is like this bill
that's like taking
the murder of 19 children to to even get
reviewed is not even close to far enough
uh
i mean it's literally just
i don't even know if it would have done
anything in this case no
but it's a good law it actually it does
have some effect on online gun sales too
i don't know the specifics about this
situation enough maybe maybe it would
have uh
had some impact on it um
i'm not sure but but the gun show
loophole thing has been around
as long as i can remember and yeah it's
just insane if you
in america
if you are a domestic abuser a violent
criminal
you can go to a gun show and buy
whatever you want there
you can buy it from another
quote-unquote private party um
oftentimes
yeah and oftentimes it's not actually a
private party it's it's some sort of gun
dealer that
they use the loophole that you know can
have a friend sell it
are you allowed to swap cars like that
no right you have to go through the dmv
get it registered you still have to yes
change the license change the
registration and everything that's crazy
you have to do that with a car that's
nuts what kind of what kind of [ __ ]
impediment to freedom is that
you're telling me i can't just swap cars
with my buddy
damn it's tyranny dude
yeah i mean i i do agree that um
what people are proposing in this hra
thing really is just
the
the bare minimum bear the bear [ __ ]
[ __ ]
minimum dude i mean treating guns it's
literally common sense yeah
it's like do you think a [ __ ]
violent criminal should be able to buy a
ar-15 without a background check yes yes
we do think that like what are you
saying
oh boy
abolish the dmv [ __ ] it
i say abolish the whole damn dmv i'm
behind that we don't need it
some people unironically believe that
yeah i'm sure
but at least be consistent you know
so
if you're asking me
i don't think ar-15 should be i don't
think you should be allowed to own that
gun straight up i think we need a a
like a serious rifle
i mean this gun is just being used too
many times it's like time and again
every time there's a shooting it's the
ar-15
okay
it's time to give it up gun people you
got to make the concession here
you gotta [ __ ] ban that gun and you
gotta ban all the guns like it for
civilian use maybe you can get it if you
get a special license and you can prove
that you have a need for that level of
gun but you gotta [ __ ] give up the
ar-15 you [ __ ] freaks because people
keep using it to kill kids okay
you gotta give up your goodies time to
make a concession all right grow the
[ __ ] up dude give away your toys dude
that's number one
number two we gotta ban these
high-volume magazines that have like 100
billion clip there's no need for that
unless you're trying to slaughter
people
i don't think you need like a high
volume magazine to go
hunt a moose
moose are pretty big a deer
or a moose let's be honest
uh you do if you're trying to kill a
bunch of people at a school though
that's for sure
and then one of these guys was using a
bump stop stop which is like a
modification where you could turn a
normal rifle into an automatic rifle uh
banned that did they ever get
successfully banned that i think they
did actually are you referring to the
las vegas yeah he was using these bump
stocks they actually banned that i think
trump actually did something about that
believe it or not but
don't get mad at me if i'm wrong about
that people are actually debating that
it's incredible they're like here's a
little here's a little tool you can use
on a rifle to make it automatic so you
could [ __ ] slay people
literally the only use for that and then
people are debating
angle from 2019 federal bump stock ban
set to go into effect tuesday as guns
right group appeal regulation the
supreme court yeah i'm sure they're
trying to fight it the nra and
everything we need our bum i don't know
what the status is on it right now i'm
fighting for the rights of the vegas
shooter
that's what the nra is like i'm fighting
for the rights of all school shooters to
use bump stocks
i'll be honest with you guys i don't
even have a problem with repealing the
second amendment that [ __ ] is antiquated
it's [ __ ] old go read that [ __ ] man
that [ __ ] was obviously written like
[ __ ] hundreds of years ago it's
talking about a well a well regulated
second amendment you guys want to
actually see what this [ __ ] says
i mean
that
not to be defeatist but that that isn't
happening that's never i know i know i'm
just saying i know that that will never
happen okay but here here's what the
constitute the second amendment says a
well-regulated militia
being necessary to secure
uh for the security of a free state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be in fringe you know
they wrote that about like muskets that
you have to [ __ ]
put a bullet in and [ __ ]
and takes like you know 30 seconds to
even prepare one round
with gunpowder
30 seconds would be good actually that's
very fast that's fast
okay now if the founding fathers saw an
ar-15 uh slaughter 19
children
um i'm listen i obviously don't have a
time machine but let's just say that's a
different [ __ ] story
i g i i personally i don't [ __ ] care
about the second amendment you know i'm
pr i think gun ownership is fine again i
have one you don't need an amendment to
guarantee it right there's not a right
to be able to drive us a [ __ ] car
i don't think it needs to be a right
and anyway it's so open for
interpretation the way it's written
a well-regulated militia [ __ ] you ain't
no [ __ ] militia
you're you're [ __ ] hank who likes to
[ __ ] have toys and shoot [ __ ]
where's your militia [ __ ]
or i saw the militia that showed up at
the school wouldn't do [ __ ] called the
police
a well-regulated militia
huh
i don't see any well regular militias
around here
i don't think we have those
you know what you know when we used
militias the revolutionary war guys
militias were huge back then
not so much in 2022
so [ __ ] your
second amendment
okay
and by the way it says you can have you
can keep weapons right
it doesn't say you can't regulate it so
shut the [ __ ] up you got to come to the
table
gun free gun people got to come to the
table
you've got to be ready to make
concessions
okay
it's time to give up the toys guys
toe your toys are killing children okay
it's time to give it up
find a new hobby i don't know what to
say find a new [ __ ] hobby besides
owning ar-15s
fun what jet skiing is really fun jet
skiing's awesome it's like way more fun
than shooting to be honest i've done
both jet skiing way cooler than shooting
a gun get a [ __ ] you know what are fun
um um airsoft guns you can go warp as a
military freak people
i'm not not to even degrade uh airsoft
guys okay that's a great hobby it looks
really fun actually fun yeah done that
too paintball
you can have a gun for self defense you
can own a shotgun
a pistol
even like a hunting rifle you don't need
a ar-15 okay
time to give up the toys
it's got to stop
it really really has to stop
[ __ ] me dude
so disturbing some other suggestions in
the chat stamp collecting
stamp collecting is a great hobby
knitting that's a good one knitting yeah
a lot of agreement with me on the
airsoft thing if you haven't been if you
haven't been jet skiing go jet ski
people it's you know and you're going up
gun ownership is is pretty expensive so
i mean that opens a lot of yeah a lot of
options for you hell yeah you know disc
golf
golf
soccer like ultimate frisbee disco just
google you know what you should just
yeah just google uh how to find a new
hobby okay
3d printing bird watching crosstalk none
of those hobbies we mention is actually
responsible for the death of children i
don't think well jet skis can be a
little dangerous
i don't want to
make a blanket statement like that well
just be careful on those jet skis
probably less dangerous than the ar-15s
i don't think you can drive a jet ski
into a school and kill dozens of kids
i don't think that unless the school's
on on a boat for some reason
so i'm just saying
it's time to grow the [ __ ] up reading a
book watching h3 that's a great i'm
gonna retire your toys okay grow the
[ __ ] up
cosplaying watching porn searching porn
i mean that's yoga bobby to some pottery
stardew valley absolutely guys listen to
all these suggestions look at all these
great things you could be doing except
collecting guns it's time to give it up
guys new hobby alert new hobby alert
blasting vivaldi yeah there you go these
are classical music incredible hobby
suggestions guys
if you guys want to like help support
the families we've confirmed that this
is legit
to the best of our ability
um there's a gofundme which will include
in the description
for the families
which has already raised 1.6 million can
you
oh it's in the dock right yeah let me
drop that in the description right now
and um
that's
you know at this point this [ __ ] happens
so much we need some kind of like
federal help to these families do you
know how expensive and how [ __ ] up and
just like how much fallout and [ __ ] you
have to deal with
uh
i think we need an emergency fund for
the families of people who die
in school shootings
okay i just added it to the description
if people refresh if they're looking for
it should pop up now
so ultimately it's like
you know we can talk about this a
million times i'll put in the chat too
and ultimately what's the answer right
what's the answer
i think people who own guns need to just
have a little bit of or not people who
are gun advocates second amendment
advocates whatever
we need them to come to the table
nothing changes
the nra needs to [ __ ]
get real okay we got to come to the
table
you got to make some concessions and i
don't know
you know people keep voting for ted cruz
uh people of texas
got gotta get real man
you gotta stop voting for ted [ __ ]
cruz who's taken over three million
dollars from the nra
i mean it's time to just become a one a
single issue voter
that's
it single issue voter
whenever your local [ __ ] comes up your
state [ __ ] federal elections
vote in it
who's the mayor who's your senator who's
your representative
look at their policy on guns
and vote for the one that's in favor of
reform
one issue
[ __ ] voting actually matters it
really does
on this issue it does on this issue it
does
uh look somebody said local funeral
homes in uvalde uvalde i hope
i keep questioning myself that i'm
saying it correctly i think it's uvaldi
have announced that they will be doing
the funerals for free for those uh who
are victims of the shooting i mean
small
people are great people are lovely you
know when this stuff happens everyone in
the community rallies around them
and everyone is super gracious and super
supportive and generous and just you
know they when you see it firsthand when
you're there people are lovely and
caring but at the large scale people who
don't [ __ ]
power hungry [ __ ] freaks like ted
cruz
they have to get
they have to get gone
yeah i see a lot of people um
asking us to talk about this thing that
happened with uh beta aurora confronting
threats pull that up i haven't seen it
uh yeah it happened right before we went
live i've been seeing all the buzz about
it uh so i saw a clear of what happened
yet but i saw a clip on twitter but i
couldn't hear what beta was saying so
maybe you guys can find a clip that um
somebody in our in our crew chat sent
one a short time ago
oh [ __ ] yeah one sec maybe he's working
on it what can we do you know it's it's
so [ __ ] up it keeps happening you're
so powerless so powerless
what a joke
all right here's beto o'rourke who
nearly won
he nearly deceited cruz actually it was
close well fairly close i mean five
percent yeah i mean it wasn't like razer
i mean five percent's a lot in the
senate race yeah and
i'll be honest
beto
not my favorite politician but it's all
relative right and if in
texas
he's running against greg at the current
great governor abbott is the [ __ ] i mean
obviously i would take baby he's a demon
he's a demon do you know what i'm saying
he's a [ __ ]
demon
look at these crusty old [ __ ] all
these white [ __ ]
look at that look at the diversity up
there
this is what the this is what the
governmental body looks like
a bunch of [ __ ]
white they're so white they're red
balding ass [ __ ] waspy [ __ ] greg
abbott is a demon and so is ted cruz
it's also disgusting god ted cruz is
such a disgusting vile person
there is one woman
shout out i didn't even notice her she's
in the shadows in the back
sucker back
there oh yeah sorry let's watch this
pass the mic to lieutenant governor dan
patrick you can crank it
excuse me
excuse me
i i can't hear what he's saying
but i can't i i could is there one where
we can hear what he's saying or this is
just what it is i think this is what it
is
he after this
it's probably best for us to just review
all of this and and show it tomorrow on
leftovers because again this happened
literally 20 minutes well i'll finish
the clip but sure um and you are doing
nothing no you're doing nothing
this isn't the place to talk too so this
is totally predictable
sure you're out of line
sure you're out you're out of line you
[ __ ] pig human
big man
god i am big man i love how they go
you're an embarrassment you're sitting
up there doing nothing you [ __ ]
demons
i'm sure you are alive shut up
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] that would come to a deal like
this to make a political issue
yeah
to make it a political issue
i again what is this galaxy brain [ __ ]
of like
gun control and you know mass murders in
this country is not political what does
that even mean
it's just their way of deflecting and
demonizing people that actually are
making any sense it's been the same
[ __ ] dog call or
it's just their it's their you know
it's their one talking point it's great
you shut down everything a fan you're
evil you're a real for wanting to
[ __ ] do something about this
said is this is on you your and then he
said uh this is totally predictable well
he's right about that
cam sent another link that he said
beto's audio is much clearer on i just
love how um
i just love how uh
indignant they get
here here's another alliance yeah
exactly
i do i challenge you to a duel
it's [ __ ]
literally with a [ __ ] walker just
just the [ __ ] [ __ ] keeper piece of
[ __ ]
here you are sir
you are doing nothing
who's yelling at him yeah no you are
online i do declare well i'd like to get
some actually uh speaking of out of line
i'd like to know more about your um
city's budget yeah please how that
affected
i'd like to know how much you're playing
actually help prevent this yeah why are
you underfunding the police so much with
only 40 you could have done so much more
you could have given 100 of the budget
to the police and maybe this thing could
have been prevented that's right
that's the mayor shut up [ __ ]
[ __ ] clown party pig ass looking [ __ ]
take your high blood pressure medicine
and [ __ ] the [ __ ] down
looks like colonel sanders
yeah i'll say it he cr his ass crawled
out of a bucket of chicken
that really is good for you the mayor uh
let's not talk about the let's not
politicize this uh
let's let's not scrutinize me while
we're here
it'd be great if we could not scrutinize
me
[Laughter]
this is not the place to do that
i wish beto went further what she
[ __ ] told that guy apparently he
outside then
basically all of the media followed him
outside instead of continuing yeah what
are they going to say anyway they're not
saying anything interesting right
exactly they're basically saying we're
praying really hard and we're not going
to do anything else
this is on you until you choose to do
something different this will continue
to happen somebody needs to stand up for
the children of this state or they will
continue to be killed just like they
were killed in ubaldi yesterday
[Music]
shut down
sit down boy
the mayor is [ __ ] two weeks away from
getting his legs amputated for
diabetes
first how about you go [ __ ] take care
of yourself and leave the city
management to someone else and cut his
legs off and serve it in a bucket right
deep fry him and [ __ ] eat him
oh yeah
you know it's crazy because like
if anyone's playing politics
if anyone's playing politics here it's
these [ __ ]
guys up on here all politics it's such
an insane statement everything is
politics like but these guys are the
ones that are dodging
the [ __ ] responsibility are trying to
let everything cool down so people
forget about it all these people accept
money from gun people in the nra and
it's in their vested interest to be like
let's not talk let's not pause let's not
politicize this let's just pray these
are the ones that are [ __ ] being
dishonest about the whole thing yeah
greg abbott
and ted cruz
these two men
are apps are [ __ ] demons dude
holy
holy [ __ ] dude
so yeah i don't know
there's really no solution right guys
we just need to vote we need gun people
to come to the table
and you know
it's it's sad but
really the only thing that could be done
is people in these very red states
to vote out these people that are
obstructing it and because
look
they're obstructing gun legislation and
in in favor and service to the nra and
gun donors
so
there's got to be people in those local
districts that care about about voting
them out i mean that's only thing that's
going to change
i mean
give me that give me that give me that a
b
the mayor appeared on good morning
america today
and he said the issue is not gun control
then mental health okay good
we was we were good we agreed that
that's a problem where's the money
where is the help
they always say this the conservatives
always says it's not guns it's mental
health where's the mental health bills
what are we doing about that issue then
if you actually cared but it's
interesting they don't actually [ __ ]
care they're okay with it they're okay
with it if they cared that we'd have
that we would have better health care
better access
to mental health
how you can't say that because nothing
ever [ __ ] happens let's take a look
at this mayor who's turning up to who's
quickly turning into the most
[ __ ] vile dude i've ever seen i'm
actually just
disgusted with this guy
let's see
you've got mayor dom mclaughlin he is
okay let's get a load of this [ __ ]
pig
just started his ninth year as mayor of
this beautiful community and and i just
first want to ask you mayor
we're all reeling obviously coming in
from the outside watching what's
happening and what's happened
this vicious heinous act of mass murder
to your community how are you feeling
well you know
i'll try to keep it straight your face
my hearts are broken around two minutes
and 50 seconds they say my hearts are
broken
my heart i've got a dif
my pacemaker and my heart are both
crying right now
i surgically had a swan heart and
planted in my chest to assist with my
blood
flow these families and for these kids
i mean uh this shouldn't happen
you know my prayers and thoughts are
with these families
thank god for the first responders that
reacted so fast thank god man
those cops are [ __ ] true heroes huh
they really are
you know those first responders that
waited 40 minutes outside
as gunshots rang
ah
that's heroism man
yesterday but this could have been a lot
worse
so
look on the bright side how could it
have been worse is this twenty
four children could have died i mean he
was in there for 40 minutes how much
more time does he need to [ __ ] kill
god how could it have been worse two
victims 19 students two teachers and the
shooter
but i mean as far as any other
information you know there we were brief
this morning but we're going to let them
release that information because there's
a lot of stuff they still don't want out
yet yeah you know i know you told me
that there's stuff they don't want out
but you said what we will find out is
is
pretty overwhelming and pretty hard to
even put into words it is it's going to
be
i mean
you know
this was a sick individual
he was
it's so sad but
maybe this
young man had mental problems i don't
know i mean clearly you don't do that
unless you're [ __ ] up
i like it when they try people they they
be like
they try him as insane they're like no
he's sane it's like no he's obviously
insane based on the act alone
i know that you have heard the cries and
and and impassioned speeches that have
taken place over the last
few hours for people calling for some
restrictions on gun control i know
you're not an advocate of it but a lot
of people are asking how did an 18 year
old just a few days or weeks after his
18th birthday not by one but eventually
two ar-15s one of which was used in this
massacre yesterday without a gun license
he doesn't even have a driver's license
why no gun license no driver's license
that is [ __ ] interesting isn't it
dude there's no regulation on guns
that's nuts man
it was only a few years ago that they uh
got rid of uh
the whole
you know what um what are they called
they're called like partials or
something
um
and in
california which you know has relatively
strict gun control laws until
just i think like two years ago
you could buy
a gun
on the internet and have it shipped
directly to your house with no
background check no anything
the loophole was the gun isn't
technically finished it comes
only partially constructed
and
you just have to do like a few more
steps to put it together
and there are technically you're
supposed to register it but obviously
people can just
buy that and never register it um and it
was only this is in california only
within the last like two years did they
finally close that up i mean it's the
actually the guns in this country it's
like it's like nobody [ __ ] these gun
people can't be inconvenienced even the
slightest bit
for the safety of children who are being
literally killed in schools
five and a half times a month we we
calculated five and a half school
shootings a month they can't be they
can't they can't be [ __ ] for just a
little bit of regulation
why is that access why should that
access be available well look i mean
again
yo
go ahead
go ahead and choke on your words as you
say what you're about to say
everybody has a right to own a gun i'm
not against i'm not against expanded
background checks okay
but everybody comes in and talks about
immediately we want to do gun control we
want to yeah we want to sanction the gun
lobbyists we want to sanction this and
we want to thank you but you know what
why don't you politicians get off your
butts and let's talk about mental health
and let's do something for real once we
[ __ ] [ __ ]
give millions of dollars to all these
countries and right now we're spending
billions down here on the border what if
we took that money and built facilities
where we could treat the people talk
about making it political
do that i think it's great do that
they've never done that
let's do both things how about that
let's do both of those things
our own country we've got homeless
people on the streets that have mental
problems we have kids that have mental
problems especially coming out with
pandemic and everybody touts their horn
and wants to beat the drum but nobody
wants to address the core product you
know how mental people
they buy guns
a license
online
okay
let's do both genius
projects
by the way he's talking to his party he
goes you all don't want to do anything
about mental health it's like you're
talking to republicans
did i hear you say though you wouldn't
be or you would be open to restrictions
of some sort i don't i'm not i mean as
far as restrictions know i'm not gonna
say i'd be in favor of history what
about having a license a gun license you
know
he won't even say that that would be
something that'll have to be i'm not
gonna you see what a coward he is even
in the wake of
this is why nothing this is why i don't
think anything's gonna change because
this mayor is such a [ __ ] coward that
even in the wake of this terrible thing
happening on his watch he's not even
willing to go out and say yes i think we
need some common sense reforms he won't
even say that
because he's afraid of you know people
voting him out right because you know
people are
people are crazy about guns there
what a coward you know
what a coward
how do you sleep at night you demon
you're going to hell bro
yo
i'm a responsible gun owner so i mean
you want to make me have a license fine
i don't have anything to hide but look i
can't believe you don't even need a
license there i mean
you don't need a license
you don't need a license
i mean
what
the the license isn't going to change
this a license wouldn't have changed
this if if
a bad guy wants to get a gun he's going
to get a gun it's proven over and over
hey i love that too it's just so
dismissive they're going to get a gun i
mean
what can we do about it and it's been
proven over and over he says
yeah five months
when has that been proven
what could we do about it mike they're
gonna get guns
i mean you could buy them online you can
buy them from gun shows you can get them
from your friends it's like should we do
something about that hell no
over again look at chicago
i mean they get guns all over you can't
even buy a gun in the city chicago but
yet they have shootings every weekend so
i mean bad guys can get guns you want to
do an expansion oh right because they
can just leave chicago and get a gun
that was gonna say it's easy to get guns
when you can go to a [ __ ] place like
texas where you don't even need a
license yeah i mean we do live in one
country california has uh strict gun
control laws but you can drive to nevada
listen to this get around most of it in
texas people 21 and older can legally
possess a handgun
and they don't need a state issued
license to carry one outside their home
or vehicle in texas you can [ __ ]
cruise with a gun without even a license
and there's at least 20 other states
have some form of permit list carry
at school we were told when we first got
there i went to school in ohio uh people
would always come and protest like
anti-lgbtq plus people would come and we
were told that like we have to be super
careful because ohio's open carry so
like we couldn't
be super combative with them because
they'll there's someone there's a chance
that they could shoot us
fun
terrifying
that's so disturbing
wow
i mean yeah how how is there going to be
any meaningful change when the mayor
uh is who is not even willing to make a
single concession i mean look how he's
like
oh
well i don't know his gears are tearing
because he's like oh i don't want to say
anything that's going to offend my
voters but oh i mean 19 kids just did
get slaughtered
how about you just go to hell demon
hope you [ __ ] die of a heart attack
soon watch a demon die thank you zack
[Laughter]
i hope you eat your last chicken legs
soon you fat [ __ ] diabetic high blood
sugar blood as your big ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] fried chicken
got my finger on the tech difficulties
button over here
i mean all of them man they're all
demons
they're unmoved they don't care
i mean these people they're pathological
these people who they hold power above
any
you know other humanity i mean for them
power is the meat is as ends
is the ends it's that that's why they're
there guys like ted cruz he he literally
doesn't care about these kids dying he
doesn't
he'll do and say anything to preserve
his spot i mean
donald trump told him that his dad
killed jfk and his wife is an ugly hog
and he [ __ ] he fellates him any
chance he gets
i mean he's a spineless [ __ ] freak
that's the problem you know most people
don't want to do politics you have to be
kind of a sociopath and especially these
conservatives because they're i mean
it's just evil what they do i'll be
honest forced birth
pro-gun
any background check i'm all for it i
have no problem
how can people watching who want to help
help the people in your community what
do you need well this morning we're
setting up uh
we've already talked to the bank and the
school district in the city and we're
getting an account set up at the first
state bank of uvalde where we're going
to try to take donations for the
monetary donations for these families
we're going to have a uh
we're going to pick somebody to
administer that fund so they're 100 is
that the gofundme we saw
well anyway uh no the gofundme is being
facilitated by a charity
um
i don't know what else to say about it
guys but
unfortunately everyone watching this
show was probably
relatively like-minded and
it's the stephen crowders and the ben
shapiro's and the dave rubins and the
ted cruz's
and all these people that you know
pander to the lowest common denominator
who are part of this gun cult who take
money directly profit
from guns being sold and not regulated
they're the ones that are going to need
to
make concessions and i just don't know
how realistic that is
like
you got gotta come to the table and we
got to figure something out
it's got to be both parties
unless they get rid of the filibuster
and they could do it tomorrow
they're not gonna do that
that's another thing man but wow
although i don't
manchin's probably
super nra right west virginia he
probably wouldn't vote for it no no no
i don't i don't actually know that for
sure but just based off of his other
positions i'm
assuming he is
a pro-gun rights guy and i mean the only
thing that we can
hope for is that enough conservatives in
these local districts
are going to care enough about
protecting children
to vote for someone that actually does
care about it
and frankly i don't see that happening
either because you know by the time ted
cruz comes up for re-election nobody's
going to remember this [ __ ] you know why
because there's five and a half school
shootings per month
okay
um
i don't know man
but if we can't fix this i think the
american experiment is over i mean
everybody wants to fix this because
basically what that proves
is that big interest
is basically trumping
the want of the people and even
something
and even in the most basic way i mean i
would say people who are in favor of uh
gun gun reform has gone to be like over
75 of all citizens possibly even higher
right
and and it just proves that we're living
in
in a our country no longer works like
and even in the most minimum way
possible
yep i mean
if nothing happens
our country as it is now
does not work
it has become too dysfunctional to
operate
period
um
and we're not even talking about banning
all guns right we're talking about like
the most basic
rudimentary
common sense gun reforms
um
oh well according to this it's only 53
of americans favor stricter gun laws so
i guess we're [ __ ]
you know what maybe we should have let
the south succeed do you ever think that
dan
maybe maybe abraham lincoln [ __ ] up
i think he sometimes i wonder if he
should have just let him go balkanize
the u.s baby that's my position do what
balkanize the u.s ball
balkanize split it up let it break up
into like 50 different countries oh my
god that'd be a disaster just call it
just call it a day this whole thing's
[ __ ] that would be so crazy
yeah i don't know i don't know
you know
not to add any more like blackpilling to
already
it is a black belt
but yeah when you say i mean passing
these common sense gun reforms it
probably will help
to an extent
um
[Music]
but i don't know
i think that there's just something
undergirding
our whole civilization right now that it
that is just really [ __ ] sick and
um
that leads people to doing these kind of
things and not not in any way to make an
excuse for this kid but i think it's
i don't know i just think it's a culture
that's that's
obsessed with violence and
individuality to an extent of
um
making people despair and just feel like
they're completely on their own and
everyone just has this
constant background anxiety that
something's wrong and that
you know life shouldn't be this shitty
and um and it's a way of people and to a
lot of people you know when we say like
oh we need to address like the mental
health i mean
this is what i think is
tormenting people to the extent that
they get so
[ __ ] nihilistic that they go shoot up
a bunch of children um
and
yeah um you know you can attack in a
number of ways you can do the gun
you can you can do both things you can
you can expand mental health care and
you can
try and restrict guns
uh more so but um
and and i'm sure that that i mean
that will help i'm not saying that it
won't
but
i don't know man like i'm just
when you you kind of jokingly said
should we just let the south secede
um
yeah i don't i don't even
i don't even think it uh
it's a joke to me anymore and it's not
just about seceding it's just about like
this entire
american experiment i don't know i feel
very pessimistic about it i don't know
if this country will exist in another 50
years as we as we know it
i don't see how it can i mean it's just
so
we just seem to be
barreling towards annihilation
uh and nobody wants to pump the brakes
and um
well since the civil war there's never
been a reconciliation not really yeah
it's the same [ __ ] conflicts we're
having then
is is spilling over now
and
yeah because we never actually addressed
any of
the core
problems
going on in this country and and in so
far you know in fact not only have we
not addressed it we now have a movement
in this country that's violently opposed
to doing so
that
thinks that it is [ __ ] up
to
teach kids
about all the things that are wrong with
our society that that's that that's
anti-american and it's great
and it's racist or whatever
to to literally just
try and understand teach kids about
slavery and native american genocide
yeah they're literally like two separate
narratives going on in terms of
that's scary people think that's fascism
i mean that's the end that's the end
that's the end of a state right there
it's so scary
but like you were saying you know
i think is like when you don't have
universal health care and it's very true
it's this individualism like to the
point of like i get mine and [ __ ]
everyone else yeah
i don't raise my taxes i'm not doing
nothing i know
i'm not paying for anyone else's health
care
that's actually people it's the you know
what it is it's the [ __ ] uh
and ran [ __ ] where it's like objectivism
it's like yeah you were responsible for
yourself and your family and nothing
else past that
and uh
i think you're right i think people
in the fringes who fall through the
crack
um end up so nihilistic right when all
the conditions it's too much the thing
is
our country our society is producing
these shooters
people like you said dan are so
nihilistic they're willing to go kill
kids go to their school kill their their
classmates
there's a cancer in this country that's
producing these people
and it's a lot of stuff
it's that individualism it's the health
care it's the culture of violence we
fetishize violence in the army
you know
and
you know it it's there was an
interesting
i learned about a stat that like 80 of
school shooters are like women hating
like uh have a said that they hate women
that's very interesting
and i think
can you pull that up i've saw yeah i'm
not floating around i mean
i i wouldn't be surprised for that to be
the case and
um
the thing is though is that
i don't think it's
misogyny directly that causes people to
do things like that or or
or even it again i i i really do think
it's something deeper than that and the
thing is is like those conditions that
create that kind of just
horrible
background anxiety that i'm referring to
um
it leads people to a lot of dark places
looking for
answers looking for
looking for a scapegoat or looking for
someone to blame for why
you know they live in the greatest
country in the history of the world uh
or so they've been told and yet their
life [ __ ] sucks
and
it's either jews or women or blacks
or gays or whatever
you know what i mean that people latch
on to and a woman is a really easy one
and it is a lot of young men that
struggle in relationships with women and
so
it
it makes sense that that just like
clicks in their mind of like oh that's
that's why my life sucks is because
women
have advances society too much and you
know they have too much power and
they're [ __ ] everything up and so i'm
gonna take it out
on them but
it's it was never really i mean in some
again i don't want to
blanket generalize too much that some
people really do just [ __ ] hate women
and that's fine
i think you're right though that i think
the misogyny is the part it's fine but
i think them is the misogyny is just
part of the same like sickness that
produced them right
but it is interesting it says what do so
many mass shooters have in common a
hatred of women
this was a study done
um
let's see there was a
university
that did a study here
uh
you're gonna have to find me an excerpt
uh uh aba
yeah but
yeah i mean listen it's like this dude
worked at wendy's okay and there's
nothing wrong with that but like
americans live in debt
and it's [ __ ] working at wendy's
for minimum wage
and knowing that your life has uh
you have no prospects in life
you have no education
you're probably in debt you're working a
dead-end job that you hate
and their future is [ __ ]
there's nothing in your future
and that is the
you know that again all the sad reality
and yeah realize all of that while the
whole time you're being told that you're
so lucky to be here right
that you live in the greatest country in
the world
and
how can that not create something in
your mind that it's like somebody's
[ __ ] me over like i'm being [ __ ]
over and you know if you go to these
really impo like you know third world
countries you don't see this stuff
even though they don't have the wealth
we have we're missing something key
to
the healthy human psyche right we're
missing some fundam fundamental needs of
a healthy human mind there's like
there's just the people are just not
getting what they need to be healthy and
that's what's producing
um these people continuously they're
being produced produced produced
produced
um
here's from the article
these men lash out at women but really
women are excused for their failure says
dr md
i'm just looking for the one that says
like
there's a percentage of guys who yeah
whatever
i mean i i'm sure you're right that it's
extremely high i mean i saw i saw i was
floating around twitter where
specifically mass shooters
80 of them have like posted about like
hating women or something whatever it
doesn't matter
yeah i don't know man
so like
i really do feel like that
there's just a he
and you know there's a huge
party that have convinced poor people
the working class people of america
that big business
and [ __ ]
individualism
toxic individualism is in their best
interest
it's crazy man
it's nuts
but yeah i mean i i think you're right
dan if like there's a big push too for
unionizations and
stuff like that and i mean healthcare
has become more accessible since
obamacare even though the rep couplings
are trying to gut it
um
there needs to be some really
tangible changes in the next like
20 years otherwise i don't see it
lasting
because people got in this form people
can't keep living like this you know
yeah i mean
here we go this is what i was looking
for thank you baby
um university of california did a
comprehensive study of school mass spree
shooters of all ages and found that the
common link between them all
is a vehement hatred of women
eighty percent had a history of domestic
violence most killed a female relative
girlfriend wife immediately prior to the
event that's interesting because that's
exactly what happened
in this one yesterday and
the sandy hook shooting you killed his
mom how how what that's just such a odd
connection where they kill
a woman in their life
first i mean that's just so odd 80
like what what is that
why are these dudes so [ __ ] angry
god damn
i don't know what it means
but
something's got to give
you know
that's crazy dude
people just need to really [ __ ] grow
up and be they got to make some
uncomfortable changes
i mean we're at a war right now you know
world war ii people gave they sacrificed
so much they gave up so much we're in a
war right now man
being a child is as dangerous being a
child in public school is as dangerous
as being a cop that's [ __ ]
incredible man
damn
well i don't know what else to say i
mean is there anything else to add to
this conversation
i don't have anything else to add um
you know thanks for everybody for
sticking around i see that the viewer
count is actually really high right now
and i know early on there were some
people in the chat that were
uh hoping that this wouldn't be the
whole episode but you know it it lasted
as long as it needed to because i think
you know this is something that is
really upset a lot of people i know you
know ethan the [ __ ] you talking about
we're talking about our country is going
to dissolve in 20 years if we don't
settle this and y'all can't sit through
one podcast where we talk about it
that was all very happy to [ __ ] care
about them in their defense but you have
to care about this stuff or we're all
going to [ __ ] die
potentially maybe
in minecraft
i'm not gonna kill them just saying
just saying
you have to care about this stuff guys
you have to you have to this is
everything
you know what part um
i was listening to the daily this
morning and they were they were talking
about this but they also brought up
sandy hook
the part that that really was striking
to me was
those sandy hook kids would have been in
high school now yeah wow that's crazy
like so young so young
so [ __ ] young
and the same with this this texas
shooting you know
it just blows my mind
i mean these kids were barely older than
my my oldest son and
just the thought of of mice my lovely
song going through something like that
um
it doesn't make sense
so i don't know
it's like
yeah
it's just incredible if you look at like
what our politicians care about even joe
biden the democrat
we have this big country we do trillions
of dollars we have the biggest biggest
businesses
and the [ __ ] he cares about
is just
meaningless in the scale of what we're
talking about like
our country is becoming irreparably
divided and violent
like we gotta work this out otherwise
this is all gonna go away
you know it's all gonna go away
nothing [ __ ] matters except trying to
fix this [ __ ]
uh it's that important
because if we can't fix this
then it all goes away it's just there's
no there's no more country
i really think that
so
we'll see
but we all got to do the most we can
which means voting
which means making sure the people
around you vote
which means holding your politicians
accountable who are who are not doing
anything about this who are who are
basically selling their soul to gun
lobbying
you know
i mean we all have to be
activated we have to vote we have to
care about this stuff that's the only
way
anything changes because
listen apathy is the uh
ultimately this country's going to go to
[ __ ] because of the apathy too i mean
people just don't give a [ __ ] they don't
vote they don't give a [ __ ] and uh
that's just as much as the problem
and in a way i get it it's hard not to
become apathetic because everything
feels so overwhelming and unmovable
right
so i get that i get that impulse but
we have to care we have to
yeah local elections are really
important guys
it's all important
all right well i don't really i'm not
going to talk about anything else it's
just
no there's no uh
you don't want to trade there's no way
to transition you want to transition
from that to uh flaming hot cheeto uh
mountain dew taste test maybe seth
green's bored ape was missing can you
believe that
what a tragedy
is very funny i feel so bad for seth
green ladies and gentlemen
that story is very funny but yeah it's
it feels like anyway anyway sorry to
those families but did you hear what
happened to seth green his board ape got
stolen
feels so bad for him
has anybody
reached out to or or heard how david is
handling all this you know i was just
thinking the same thing david dobrev
because he is the victim he's the i
think david dobrik is the real he's a
real big god i'm sure
[Music]
guys
is this gonna affect him i wonder
that's tough for david man it's tough
it's tough it's tough
it's really your mind goes to him at a
time like this
all right that's it that's the show for
today guys
we'll be back tomorrow morning live
leftovers with hassan 10 a.m yeah i mean
obviously we're going to be talking
about this again tomorrow on leftovers
but something that
i thought would make it so we're not
just retreading all of the same ground
is i've collected a bunch of and i've
ian while we've been working or while
we've been doing the show has been
collecting more
has been collecting the absolute
most
[ __ ] insane takes you've ever
that's what i look forward to tomorrow
um
are you aware of the fact that uh
a fake rumor that started on 4chan that
the shooter was a trans person has been
picked up by the likes of candace owen
and even though they've been corrected
continue to state that this was a
uh deranged trans child and someone said
that
i saw our boy go sergeant and so did
paul gosar so did several others paul
gosart who famously his whole family
made a hit video about it yes do not
vote for this we're his family and we
all [ __ ] hate his guts he's still one
by the way still won
so yeah so for leftovers we we will have
a lot of people to well there'll be more
less less
less uh coping and evaluating like there
was today more dunking yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
all right guys well
be well
and uh we'll see you tomorrow morning
all right guys take care
you